tutti ragazzi è pervenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono marco berlino e oggi siamo
su quel gioco guarda oggi volevo provare
una roba un po diversa che non ho ancora
fatto che però secondo me potrebbe avere
un senso oggi facciamo una puntata
dedicata ad uno shock in che senso
come quando fanno quelli con le puntate
speciali nelle serie tv dove si dedicano
un personaggio ok fa e selezione per
personaggio viti seleziona i livelli
solo di quel personaggio facciamo solo
quelli di nonno ciak
proviamo a iniziare col primi gli faccia
a caso e ragazzi non lo so li faccio
completamente a random questo è uno dei
livelli più cosa sto vedendo questa è
l'ora dei livelli più votati vi è più
disco non ci va bene
cosa devo fare dovrete piccione è
notevole e la madonna
salve tutto a posto allora fatemi capire
un secolo un tizio europea eccolo
ciao zio tutto bene a posto mi scusi ma
nessuno tipo come se io non mi sono
fatto niente come se fossi sceso al
divano o nulla guarda che bravo che sono
ti fai passare per favore ci ha dato
tutto e ho dato l'osso ti ha dato
porca vacca ma che cane sei bravo figo
come possibile cane killer joe è
comunque non ho ben capito il
dovrebbe arrivare al suo livello però
penso sia il massimo questo starving
poco che sarebbe asi questo la muffa tu
questo lo avevo fatto che lo ricorda
questo quale a livello pixelato quello
famosissimo nino altro tutto a posto
tra l'altro è una cosa da fare ma
scusami questo se non l'avete lo
rifaccio perché i ragazzi uno dei più
bei livelli di df se non avevo detto
anche l'ultima nata è fatto benissimo è
un ep vis pixelato sembra mac pikes peak
ma se non vi ricordate nei pixel siete
le brutte persona nessun che ho preso la
moneta non ho ben capito dove deve
arrivare per tutto questo sto perdendo
vita quindi o muovermi scala perfetto
stato ogni volta che salta il sound
effetto è questo se non ha un senso
gioco però ci dovremmo essere raga
ho fatto fuori anche un tizio madonna
che il pro gamer qui fa sempre vivere st
livello eccoli gli avevo gia fatti
sicuro come questo qua che questo
l'avevo già fatto un episodio
sicuramente però sono tra i più belli
mai fatti quindi ci può stare è il
veroli oren pecs le olimpiadi dei vecchi
va bene che cosa sto vedendo e mo e gli
act che che vuol dire a troppo onde
nuvola va bene già parto svantaggiato
per soli piani che non so non so niente
non c'è una casa di euro cose ma
rifacciamo ragazzi graham che sia
veramente difficile ragazzi comunque non
la nota la tua perfezione let's go così
già scritto
[Musica]
tutto bene tutto a posto non ho capito
niente quello che è successo ma super
meat boy conosciamo ha tra l'altro non
doveva uscire super meat boy adesso e ci
pensa super meat boy ragazzi avranno
annunciato nell'aprile 2019 e passato
più di un anno c'è ragazzino non sto
scherzando super meat boy forever il
seguito di super meat boy sarebbe dovuto
uscire
nell'aprile del 2019 l'anno scorso in
giappone con gianandrea ricordo ancora
che dicevi che non tornerò mai in tempo
a casa prima che esca super meat boy
patema più nel culo se lo faranno tutti
io non lo farò
e lo farò settimane dopo che è uscito
perché sono qui in giappone è invece
ancora non è uscito ragazzi ci è passato
più di un anno ma che cacchio sta
facendo e la terra una trovata non
esiste nessun super meat boy è una presa
per il culo
ok ok ho fatta perfetto proprio lui
saab fifty wine wiser tutti come sempre
sono i migliori
questi ragazzi di guidolin assoluto prof
se trovo livello brutto chi li denuncio
complete test di release non del piano
vai piano testo il numero uno
e vabbè ma che test sono ho capito che
suonano ciak però un po di pietà ok devo
andare piano immagino madonna siamo
ormai sono vivo per miracolo
perfetto che maestria test completo
destina merci non sembra portal comunque
no no vi sono tre portando questo non è
un buon segno perfetto no perché non ho
fatto quando si cappotta in casinò test
number two
o mio dio
regola
che sfiga cao perfetto ok va bene
andiamo avanti c'è un'ansia incredibile
test 3 all'uscita tensione c'erano solo
due teste e quindi la spiaggia terzo
sicuro termination no party a mark via
via via via trovata sono fuggito solo
bravissimo scappa oddio ci sono un sacco
di nomi già testati va dai un
laboratorio di in ogni ciak
ecco perché ce ne sono così tanti non
tutti gli episodi no mio dio faccia farò
mai supera sta cagando del rigore
facciamo finta di aver vinto facciamo
finta ragazzi solo finta ma con le asp
movie highlights claims dal quarto tempo
mi mancava su movie mano bellissimo
oddio the trade dentro ricard balls ok
minchia distrutto la tartaruga dai play
off
qualcuno di voi ha mai vista movie spero
di sì perché la storia di youtube
nel caso studiate continuiamo demoni
casa you bello almeno lì almeno allegro
perfetto sono già morto e ma perché loro
non rimette anzi ragazzi non ci posso
fare niente di sopra
tanto chi ha bisogno delle gambe a
sinistra va bene agli ordini perché
stiamo andando
c'è una chiave ho preso una chiave ma è
la madonna e paranormale est ragazzi è
giusto
fatemi uscire ma ce lo slider merda cosa
c'entra colpiscilo bravo colpiscilo
ancora tanto non è ma lo slider man
imbattibile che ci devo fare zio tre le
porte c'è scritto zio 3 va bene ma se
vado lì sotto domanda cosa succede
esce un altro ascensore 18
risolto il mio vedere jive e senza 420
mica per caso
diamo forza mi sa che di sotto io non ci
devo andare ma non ne sono completamente
convinto l ho visto i suoni perfetto ai
amap lanciato un coltello ma che cacchio
l'isola in terminerà a herat un gas a ma
tu non lo puoi uccidere e morire per
forza i soldi allora non è fatto così
livello ria prova a superarlo non si può
andare avanti quindi livello e questo
finito attaccato potranno farlo fiat non
lo puoi uccidere
allora basta ero together tirato addosso
di tutto sto pezzente cavallo uccidilo
era d'estate allo slam jerman e quando
mai
leoni sopra dello stato brad fuori ma
morì a chi ci sta seguendo 18 sicuro
devo correre quando corri corri corri dr
basta steve jobs che air ma che livello
è ragazzi parte che il jobs kassovitz
non possono far paura ma che è tutto a
posto
non so cosa succede e vabbè dove come ci
arrivo è ma non lo posso capire 26 volte
vado lì sotto
mi ci butto spr
arriva ammazzo ti ammazzo di idee nonno
ciak alaskan fisherman un pescatore
dell'alaska
vediamo già il fatto che il livello ci
mette tanto a caricare gli fa capire
perfetto
chi sono io cosa sto vedendo io sono
dentro la barca c'è dentro la e dentro
la barca non ho già ma io veramente
stupido da una barca siete scemi nonno
jacques mori ci facesse fila a david
peat enea devi colpire il devi usare il
machete quando passa la gente è proprio
family friendly sto livello rubbish col
le collezioni immondizia lì dietro va
bene e lei mi scusi etnico dice così il
livello
volevo tagliare solo la zucca in realtà
è la zucca impatta come possibile ma è
bellissimo perché ti rilassa ragazzi
sono e rilassante di cosa stiamo
parlando serve perché a una sedia
infilata nel culo ci penso io
signori in questo momento io vorrei
concludere questa puntata di happy meals
dicendogli che farò altri episodi questa
roba con gli altri personaggi volevo con
cui visto che siamo in un momento
rilassante volevo concludere dicendo vi
quanto per me è importante l'estate
importanti beauty cristiani e arriveremo
a due centesimi episodio che
probabilmente sarà uscito happy with due
è appena uscita è più visse due inizierà
un nuovo capitolo delle nostre vite
è riuscito anche a finire
mentre finito il mio discorso questo
significa proprio che io e poi se siamo
fatti l'uno per l'altro non c'è verso
signori ho detto tutto lasciatemi piace
schiacciato la campanella era ci vediamo
al prossimo video è la ragazza
[Musica]